it's gorgeous it's Grand
spectacular magnificent classical and
modern at the same time inspiring
the Dome to me is really the signature
space of MIT it's on t-shirts it's on
greeting cards hacks happen on the Dome
the police car the fire truck also while
we were building the project we got
hacked a very nice Pac-Man hack
it's what you see in Killian Court when
you're waiting to graduate
when you think of MIT you think of the
great Dome
The Barker library is directly
underneath the great Dome
some people definitely avoided it
because you know it was just a little
too dark maybe people found it you know
a little dismal Batcave like
there were hardly any Windows really no
natural light
the biggest challenge was trying to
replicate and restore a design and
construction technology that was a
hundred years old
foreign
I love that there's a glass Oculus
glass comes alive in the presence of
light and so when the sunlight comes
down through the Oculus and through the
different layers it's alive and it makes
the space alive and it makes the people
that are working inside the space I
think feel livelier and more motivated
and more inspired to do what they're
here to do
you can see the architecture of the
inside of the dome in ways that you
couldn't before
they use shades of
pretty neutral colors but because of the
perspective of the room
there actually appear to be more
gradations in the color and that effect
really highlight the architectural
features in the space
I think it's really important to have
some time to unwind as well as to
reflect and think the Barca engineering
library and reading room to me serves as
that place it gives me physical space to
think
as well as it gives me a time to reflect
and look inwards
by opening the door we're really saying
for the next 70 years
the sky is the limit for all of us
the Dome really represents that ideal at
MIT of reaching out to a wider community
now we not only have a lot of students
come in but we have alumni who come in
who want to see the space being so
different than when they were there
it's a destination point it's a
Gathering Place but it's also a thinking
place so I think it has a great future
the potential of the space has finally
been realized